Cruz's latest mission is facing an
uphill battle thanks to Christopher
Nolan's Oppenheimer unfortunately it
looks like Crews won't get a hold of
Nolan's iMac screens as Universal
Pictures the studio behind Oppenheimer
locked them down all the way back when
the World War II Epic was dated
Oppenheimer holds all IMAX screens in
North America and certain territories
for three weeks cruised focusing on
securing his many plf or premium large
format screens that aren't IMAX to show
how serious he is Cruz has been
personally calling exhibitors and execs
pitching why dead reckoning is better
bet for them than Barbie or Oppenheimer
he's reportedly told a summer box office
adversaries that it's a smart idea for
them to give up their plf screens or
move their release dates of course this
won't happen which is why all eyes are
on the summer box office champion of
2023 expectations are sky high for the
latest Mission outing with a budget of
nearly 300 million dollars as per The
Hollywood Reporter dead reckoning part 1
has a long way to go before it can boost
profits which is why every dollar counts